Сегодня я хотел бы поговорить с вами о
том как выжимать максимум из общения с
другими людьми К сожалению большинство
людей относится к общению как-то
безалаберно они относятся к общению так
как будто Ну это что-то такое
естественное над которым даже не надо
задумываться это как вот дышать воздухом
вот мы все дышим воздухом и
соответственно какой смысл задумываться
над этим но на самом деле это не всегда
так потому
что смотрите все возможности в этой
жизни приходят из людей Но для того
чтобы возможности приходили в вашу жизнь
вам нужно общаться определённым образом
таким образом вам надо научиться
правильно строить коммуникации я сейчас
не говорю про тот случай коммуникации
Когда вы просто а общаетесь чисто для
того чтобы поржать весело провести время
с друзьями и так далее Хотя даже в этом
случае у вас должна быть чёткая Цель
этого общения потому что цель общения
Когда вы общаетесь с друзьями у такого
общения тоже есть цель поднять ваше
настроение и весело провести время и
отдохнуть таким образом из чего же
строится правильное эффективное Общение
для того чтобы А у вас появилось больше
возможностей или больше людей хотели бы
с вами общаться общаться или делать
бизнес и так далее так вот прежде всего
вам нужно ответить на вопрос Зачем вам
общаться зачем вам с кем-то общаться
поэтому прежде чем общаться с кем-то
если вам назначили встречу Или вы сами
хотите Назначить встречу или хотите
пойти на какое-то мероприятие Вы должны
чётко
понимать с кем вы собираетесь общаться И
самое главное зачем одно дело когда вы
идёте на какую-нибудь свадьбу у вас
может быть в голове возникнут ответ на
вопрос Зачем я иду Просто поддержать
своего друга или родственника там в его
там
хорошее там Важное событие его жизни но
в то же время в зале очень много людей с
которым вы так или иначе будете общаться
поэтому важно всё-таки в голове
сформулировать свой запрос Особенно это
касательно деловых встреч Зачем вы идёте
общаться если а условно вы хотите
запустить новый проект и вы ищете
партнёра то сразу настраивайте и И
общайтесь только с теми людьми которые
потенциально могут стать вашими
партнёрами Поэтому в любом общении очень
важно сначала ответить себе на вопрос
Зачем мне нужно это общение многие люди
могут подумать что когда я говорю что
сформулируете цель зачем Общаться Теперь
у них Вот это пропадёт человечность и
они всё время теперь как роботы Будут
думать Какова цель моего общения на
самом деле совсем не так Я имею в виду а
только деловую среду или среду общения
Когда вы вам что-то нужно Вы хотите
добиться какой-то цели понятно что когда
вы общаетесь с родственниками вы
общаетесь с друзьями Когда вы просто
отдыхаете Вы можете общаться как угодно
вы интуитивно понимаете зачем вы
общаетесь Вы общаетесь что чтобы весело
провести время отдохнуть похота и так
далее Я имею в виду деловое общение
Когда вы едете какую-то
конференцию на какой-то форум Когда вы
находитесь или вас позвали на какую-то
встречу или вы кого-то позвали на
встречу когда есть вероятность что вы
встретите потенциального партнёра или
клиента вот я имею в виду надо Быть
готовым именно к таким случая Наверняка
у каждого из вас в жизни были периоды
Когда вы дали в неловкую ситуацию когда
вам нужно было Чётко и быстро
сформулировать цель вашего общения либо
когда вас спрашивали чем вы занимаетесь
А вы сумбурно отвечали или сбивчиво
отвечали и так далее вы не были готовы к
разговору и наверняка были случаи когда
вы пожалели о том что вы не были
подготовлены к такому разговору либо
напишите другой случай когда вы очень
много бесцельно общались с человеком
хотя с этим человеком можно было бы
сделать какие-то местные проекты
какие-то совместные дела То есть вы по
сути бесцельно сожгли тот то время
общения которое можно было бы
использовать с пользой И третье что я
хотел бы попросить вас обязательно
Напишите как вы применяли ролевое
поведение в жизни я 100% уверен вы это
подсознательно применяли и просто
вспомните такие случаи когда вы меняли
отношение к человеку и этот человек
автоматически менялся в ответ вот это
меня интересует
второе вам нужно чётко определить с кем
общаться после того как Вы ответили
зачем Общаться вам нужно определить с
кем общаться это тоже очень важно если
вы ищете партнёра то ясно же что
бесполезно общаться с кем попало там с
кем угодно с таксистами с официантами и
так далее с кем общаться Это очень
важный вопрос в зависимости от вашей
цели опять-таки третье ответьте себе на
вопрос о чём общаться то есть заранее
сформулируйте в голове определённый
каркас вашего общения то есть вы сначала
представляете себя потом у вас
непринуждённый разговор а потом вы
начинаете там закидывает какую-то удочку
то есть чтобы привлечь внимание
собеседника и на вопрос Или на его
интерес ответьте коротенькое презентации
того чем вы занимаетесь и что Вы ищете
например
поэтому
обязательно для себя в голове имейте
картинку О чём сказать потому что
зачастую очень часто происходит так что
вот вы идёте на какое-нибудь мероприятие
или в каком-нибудь бизнес-центре зашли в
лифт и случайно получилось так что вы
встретили человека который точно мог бы
стать вашим партнёром либо
проинвестировать А у вас нету в голове
схемы разговора и вы начинаете сумбурно
неструктурированной вы приезжаете на
свой этаж или ваш собеседник приезжает
на свой этаж выходит из лифта и вы не
добились своей цели поэтому всегда в
голове держите определённую конструкцию
вашего будущего разговора с
потенциальным партнёром либо клиентом
либо
там другим человеком Ну из сферы ваших
интересов четвёртое очень важное принцип
- Это для себя сформулируйте или
ответите на вопрос как общаться Вот
здесь интересный момент Дело в том что
как общаться - это не про то как там
держать
осанку смотреть в глаза улыбаться и так
далее это естественно составляющие Когда
вы проявляете интерес к собеседнику у
вас это должно происходить естественно я
сейчас хотел бы поговорить о другом Я
хотел бы с вами поговорить о таком
феномене как ролевое поведение Дело в
том что мы все люди и у всех людей есть
определённая склонность быть
предсказуемыми это прямо вшита у нас в
генах быть предсказуемыми мы боимся быть
непредсказуемыми вообще про
непредсказуемых людей в обществе Говорят
он неадекватный непредсказуемых людей
люди сторонятся
И вообще предсказуемость поведения она
формирует доверие вот если вы смотрите
на человека ожидаете от него одно
поведение а он вдруг начинает вести себя
по-другому вы понимаете что этот человек
немного неадекватен и вы не
автоматически перестаёте ему доверять
так вот вы можете использовать этот
механизм адекватности или
предсказуемости поведения человека так
вот предсказуем человек в рамках
определённых ролей Вы должны понимать
тко
что в единицу времени человек всегда
выполняет какую-то роль например роль
хорошего отца роль бизнесмена роль
руководителя роль друга роль партнёра и
так далее вы даже это можете заметить В
общении с некоторыми людьми как они тут
же меняют своё поведение То есть когда
например с ва с вами ен Может быть как
держать какую-то официальную позицию а
потом подходит его друг и они очень
быстро как-то переходит на дружескую
ноту быстро так общаются как-то на
коротке называют себя какими-то
сокращёнными именами и так далее То есть
он резко перешёл от роли там строгого
партнёра или потенциального партнёра в
роль друга так вот когда вы общаетесь с
каким-либо человеком очень важно сразу
же на него как пальто одеть ту роль
которая выгодна вам а Какая роль может
быть выгодна вам отнеситесь к этому
человеку так как будто он ваш старый
знакомый которому вы сильно доверяете
отнеситесь к нему как порядочно человеку
как честному человеку как хорошему
человеку как доброму человеку и вас это
удивит вы удивитесь как на ваших глазах
Этот человек начнёт отыгрывать ту роль
которую вы на него одели и здесь ещё
очень важно когда вы в голове держите
роль этого человека и начинаете к нему
относиться как порядочно хорошему
доброму человеку это меняет тон вашего
разговора меняет тембр меняет вообще ваш
внешний вид к нему вашу улыбку и этот
человек считывает Какую роль вы на него
одели и он на подсознательном уровне
будет отыгрывать эту роль Это очень
сильный лайфхак который я уверен поможет
вам а в жизни ещё приведу Пример
например Когда вы встречаетесь с
ГАИшником или любым представителем
власти он приходит э в роли официального
полицейского у него погоны у него форма
он должен быть строгим а если вы
откроете окно и скажете ой брат или там
Ой извините там А вот так-то так-то
получилось вы мне могли бы помогать То
есть начнёте ему относиться как своему
брату или причём как к родному брату Да
или к отцу или опекуну или вот
перестанете видеть его погоны а будете
видеть в нём хорошего доброго
отзывчивого человека вы сразу же увидите
Как изменится и голос полицейского и его
отношение к вам и сразу же пропадёт вот
этот холод в ваших отношениях Попробуйте
Попробуйте я рекомендовал бы вам
провести такое упражнение когда вот
завтра или когда вы встретите
незнакомого человека Попробуйте в
мысленно одеть на него роль и нач и
Попробуйте относиться к нему Так а как
требует эта роль и посмотрите на его
обратную реакцию как он будет себя вес
вести этот лайфхак действительно творит
чудеса в своём Telegram канале Я даю
много аудио подкастов и лайфхаков на
тему общения ссылку на Telegram оставлю
под этим видео подписывайтесь на мой
Youtube канал и следите за свежими
выпусками пока